yeah actually going off and hentai you
mentioned in joey's interview last time
that you were working you were voice
acting in a hentai soon
i was very curious one if you can talk
about it now and two what the entire
process is like
i assume it's not the low budget aero
games that these two are playing when
they're growing
hey man don't don't get out yeah we want
to know more about this uh hentai voice
actually however the production has been
delayed because of kobe 19.
also supposed to come out like sometime
soon uh we
haven't filmed yet i had an audition and
like i got a role
but we cannot film yet because it
increased a lot of mourning and gonna
ah alright you know this must be like
the final boss versus like
you cannot keep in our social distance
i imagine like you going into that
audition was like saitama going into
like a kids boxing game
like it was just like oh yeah this is
easy this is easy mode it was so
difficult at first because like there
are pictures already
there right that's the difference
between normal anime and
hentai anime because i mean they got all
the pictures ready for you
but no more like a regular anime they
haven't it's just a rough image yeah
yeah yeah yeah
speak however you want like within this
amount of time so the hentai is like
fully
yeah you have to like you know match oh
so all hentai is actually dubbed ten
times
so you have to match like the moans and
everything with what's going on on the
screen
that was hard i feel that hentai voice
actors have it so much like harder than
regular voice actors because like
especially if like you're female because
there are some scenes that i'm just like
damn this must be like totally on their
throat
and you cannot get too into it because
like the next scene it could be like
something
could be the biggest knot okay
it could be an even bigger one you know
i mean i just i don't i wouldn't know i
don't watch any
any bad things oh yeah of course
of course you don't know i i i like i
think we can all agree that
like it'd be cool if we could like voice
acting i would love to voice that would
be great
just for the experience alone right like
my audience will never let
like me go for it yeah but like they'll
probably never take me seriously ever
again but yeah
i've watched in a yowie where i did a
sex scene oh no i i haven't had anyone
bring that up to me much
yeah but that's because you're 93
percent yeah that's very true i made my
own no one would hire me to do hentai so
i was like [ __ ] it i'm going to make my
own you're going to make your own i'm
going to make my own i made my own
yowie audiobook where i just moaned nice
audio book yeah you get to hear it like
surround sound
six inch surround sound connor moaning
did you ever shout come like seven times
now no but you know like
when i was voicing it right you would
you would do it and you're like i'm
already getting pretty loud and then
like you said like you turned the page
and you're like i've got to get louder
than this
like this is the climax like how do you
like i mean i've never had experience
having to like screech
like coming at the top of my lungs
before but he was in the manga so i had
to replicate that and i'm like
it's a very strange process because it's
so hard to fake
come that loud because in real life i
would never shout when coming yeah
because in real life you'd just be like
and also i don't want to disturb
yeah my voice already travels through
walls yeah yeah yeah
it's like the low vibrations that travel
through the walls yeah yeah i think i
haven't
did i tell you this guys like when my
old one of my old houses the walls were
so thin
that my voice had like the same natural
frequency
as the walls so when i spoke they would
always vibrate
wait your voice cannot show like it's
just naturally
resonates like everywhere yeah we've had
comments every now and then on the
podcast where people are just like i
actually can't understand what connor is
saying because it's going like
sometimes it just sounds like mumbles
it's so deep it just sounds like whoa
like just like a subwoofer yeah yeah
yeah yeah
in your voice like oh my god i wasn't
listening i'm gonna go yeah
it's too great i i i remember
it was so weird because when my voice
broke i was like 13 when i started to
sound like this oh right could you
imagine like
what did you sound like before very high
pitched really it's it's always those
ways because i've seen some clips
of like the official movie trailer
voices and how they got their voice and
apparently
they every one of them had really really
high voices
and then it just dropped like that one
yeah people thought i was messing around
like they thought i was joking because i
used to do voices like all the time like
oh my god you know like way
like do dumb voices so when i came into
school and my voice started like getting
like
yo yo whatever like people were like
what the
[ __ ] is conan faking this i was like no
no i don't know what happened i think
it's a sore throat or something but i'm
gonna be fine
a week later i still have it and i'm
like what the hell so wait did it just
happen like overnight or
i think it happened over like a week or
two right
i don't know is that is that how it
happens i have no idea how it happened i
think mine just dropped
immediately i think it's just like it's
like a snap i did do you remember
i don't remember now that i think about
it no you gotta well because you listen
to your voice every day right so
like the subtle differences you can't
hear yeah so you're just like oh [ __ ] i
guess
my voice is here now like i didn't
realize that i used to like scare the
youngest kids in the hallway i would
walk behind them and i'd be like
yo yo what up yo and they would be
spontaneous i'm just like walking like
what's up
the moment you turn around you should be
like hey